Read printed documents with Seeing AI.
Seeing AI’s document channel enables you
to read the text of a document.
Now, OCR’s been around for quite some time.
However, with the mobile phone taking a picture
of a document can be quite challenging.
To help with this, we detect the edges of
a document and provide guidance on how to
position the phone.
And once we recognize that text in the document,
we go a step further by also detecting the
formatting which enables you to navigate more
easily using voiceover’s navigation commands.
So here I have a document, and as I put the
phone over it.
> No edges visible
I hear that no edges are visible.
> Top and left edges not visible.
Because it has detected the presence of a
document and straight away, it’s giving
me guidance.
And you also heard it say, 2 edges weren’t
visible etc.
Instead of moving the phone around and manually
taking the picture, I am going to use a different
technique that I personally find to be useful.
Which is to put the camera in the center of
the document.
And a camera remember is not in the middle
of the phone, but on the top right corner
normally.
So let’s do that.
> No edges visible.
And making sure it stays parallel, I’m going
to lift the phone up.
> Left edge not visible.
I’m going to keep moving away.
> Processing.
And it took the photo itself.
> Standard lease agreement.
> Heading level one.
Great so it recognized that text.
It sounds pretty accurate.
And you heard it say, heading level one, because
it is also understood the formatting.
And that’s great because I can use voice
over to navigate by headings, for example.
Just to give you an idea of how accurate it
is, I am going to swipe through a bit more
of this document.
> This agreement executed on May 5th 2017
by and between.
I am gonna pause it there because it’s so
boring legal document.
But I hope that gives you an idea.
So there we have it, reading a document with
Seeing AI.
Microsoft logo appears.